how do you flow with POI flowers if
you're one of the many people who
learned how to do POI inpin flowers last
week from my tutorial you might be
pondering this very question right now
how do you do transitions what other
tricks complement those flowers are
there any dance moves that go well with
them if any of these questions have
crossed your mind then I've got you
covered this month I'm offering a
special live stream class called flowing
with POI flowers that will give you
absolute control over your flowers in
this class I'll teach you basic
transitions in and out of your inpin
flowers dance moves that make for a
great compliment to those flowers and
I'll even teach you a 30second PO combo
that will bring all the pieces together
and teach you how to flow like a pro
this class is for beginners but it'll
work for all levels and it'll last 4
weeks starting April 16th join us every
Tuesday evening starting at 700 p.m.
Eastern to flow grow and learn something
cool to show your friends and family and
if you're not available at that time
slot no worries all classes are recorded
so you can watch and rewatch them at
your convenience registration is open
now at drexfactor
docomo flowers come wiggle with me